proud mama Christina Aguilera's also all
about first that includes raising two
kids while on the road only Nietzsche
was invited to hang with Christina
Turing the LA stop before liberation
tour and as Kelty found out well things
are very different for Xtina this time
around miss Fang in red tell me what
want your fans to take away oh my God
we're in LA and I just got emotional
just now because you know it's been a
long time in the making and my fans have
been so patient while I you know to time
out to you know be with my family be a
mom I truly am just so grateful ET was
given an exclusive all-access pass
behind the scenes of the liberation tour
it's Christina's first tour and more
than 10 years I love you all have an
amazing show it also marks the first
time hitting the road as a mom her son
Max is 10 daughter summer is 4 I mean
it's it's it's a lot of extra work but
it's amazing it's not all about me you
know it's different from touring when
you're 21 years old and you have to
think about it yourself it's like no no
no we're thinking about you know the
blankies and the favorite stuff eases
you know it's all the mom stuff it's a
far cry from her strict days which just
celebrated a big milestone
[Music]
I mean it's insane you know I just
celebrated the 16th sweet 16 of the
strip record but birth all my fighters
and the chaps and you'll see some of
that tonight you know that the show is
actually such a great celebration of the
old and this plastic material each his
first interview with Christina was
nearly 20 years ago on the 1999 video
set up genie in a bottle I've always
always always wanted to be a singer and
now it's like I'm really doing it I
think doing my first music video but
then 18 year old was following in the
footsteps of her fellow Mickey Mouse
Club alum Britney Spears do you feel
like you're the next one to break out I
do I do I mean I may speak confidently
when I say that but I I know my time
will come soon I'll be joining Britney
soon me but best friend end of the
Mickey Mouse Club
should we have a reboot would you be
involved an actual reboot I mean now I
love those guys I mean are you kidding
me Ryan Gosling Justin and Britney me we
definitely need some kind of a reunion
at some point Oh wouldn't that be great
and listen to this Britney actually told
me that long ago that she would be up
for a reunion that the Mickey Mouse Club
was like one of the best times of her
life so hey I say let's do it girls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]